j'ai sorti un nouveau livre et cette
fois a surpris surprise il s'agit d'un
livre à ses cours de science fiction qui
parle notamment de kaka et
d'intelligence artificielle
ce livre a été coécrit avec tristan de
la chaîne risque alpha et il est
disponible en français également en
anglais et oui et le livre en question
s'appelle smart poupe il raconte
l'histoire d'une entreprise du numérique
smart coupe ou kaka intelligent dans la
langue de la start up nation qui
effectuent des analyses automatisé
d'excréments ce qui lui permet des
diagnostics médicaux ultra perfectionnés
cependant dans chaque chapitre le
déploiement de smart poupe conduit à des
effets secondaires imprévus avec des
conséquences médicales et sociales
tragique les cofondateurs de smart poupe
les héros de l'histoire doivent alors
prendre la responsabilité de leur
technologie en subir les conséquences et
trouver des solutions pour rendre leurs
algorithmes sécurisé et éthiques
l'objectif de la science fiction en plus
de divertir bien sûr c'est de
sensibiliser un grand public aux enjeux
de l'éthique de l'information et des
algorithmes à travers des exemples
extrêmement parlant et réalistes et avec
malheureusement aussi beaucoup
d'inspiration qui viennent tout droit de
l'actualité oui par exemple smart poupe
et initialement une application avec
laquelle l'utilisateur photographie
c'est celle c'est extrêmement et qui
effectue un diagnostic médical simpliste
à partir de là du genre ah oui
effectivement cette diarrhée ressemble à
une grosse gare et du coup au début bain
sans surprise c'est un gros flop
l'application jusqu'au jour où une
pandémie dévastatrice bouleverse
complètement les besoins un diagnostic
précoce de la société est bon la
pandémie en question ce n'est pas le
comité 19 parce que le coronavirus n'est
pas vraiment associé à être attirés dans
l'histoire de smart poupe la pandémie en
question c'est une pandémie d'euros vide
19 ou le r coassements rotavirus qui est
l'un des virus les plus courantes
la pièce le livre explore de nombreux
thèmes comme la diffusion de la
mésinformation les billets algorithmique
la protection des données personnelles
l'injection de fausses données la
gouvernance des algorithmes à travers à
chaque fois des cas concrets où un
utilisateur voir tout un pays souffre
gravement de ces files algorithmique et
à l'instar du livre de monsieur fils
marc poupe et bourré de notes de bas de
page pour les plus scientifiques parmi
vous qui soit être le comprendre la
crédibilité scientifique et l histoire
mais aussi tous les liens qui a entre
l'histoire racontée et le développement
des algorithmes et plus dangereux du
monde moderne et je parle bien sûr des
algorithmes de google de facebook et
donc histoire de vous donner envie
d'acheter ou d'offrir la version papier
de ce livre auto publié sur amazon ou
simplement d'en télécharger gratuitement
et parfaitement légalement la version
électronique sur github publié sous
licence creative commons attribution on
vous propose la lecture d'un petit
extrait du premier chapitre
en mai 2000 20 alors que les nombres de
cas diminue lentement mais demeure
encore très élevé smart poupe récolte
quotidiennement des centaines de
milliers de photographies au total
smartbook dispose alors de dizaines de
millions de photos d'excréments
malheureusement si les algorithmes de
katia distingue aisément les diarrhées
de l'hérault sanglante des cases avancé
il et joue encore à détecter une
quelconque différence entre les cases
infecté près symptomatique et les cassin
katia est frustré ça semble peine perdue
s'exaspère t elle auprès de marc tu
regrettes encore nos efforts non non je
pense que cette fois le pari était bon
il y avait peu de chances que smart
poupe résolvent la crise dure vie 19
mais si c'était le cas on aurait sauvé
l'humanité bon c'est pas le cas mais
cette fois je pense qu'on a bien fait
d'essayer ça n'en reste pas moins
frustrant
déçu marc reconnaît que les confinements
vont probablement s'éterniser
probablement pendant des années le temps
qu'un vaccin efficace soit développer
tester et déployer à très grande échelle
si tenté qu'il voit le jour un jour
pendant ce temps l'euro vide 19 ne
cessera de se diffuser
en entendant ces mots katia se lève
agitant son index droit qui illustre le
bouillonnement intellectuel qui anime
ces neurones se diffuser mais oui c'est
ça katia se jette alors sur son
ordinateur et se met à coder marque la
suit et demande des explications quelle
est la nouvelle idée de katia
le virus durvy 19 se diffuse
particulièrement bien à travers les
flatulences explique katia mais de ce
que je comprends d'habitude les
flatulences ne diffuse pas très loin car
nous portons des culottes et des
pantalons bon aussi des jupes et des
robes mais oublions les jupes et les
robes elles sont interdites depuis des
mois maintenant pour que leur vie 19 se
diffuse vraiment bien il doit
probablement affecter la manière dont
les gars se sont produits et se diffuse
mais ce gaz il doit aussi être présents
dans les excréments et on devrait le
voir mais pas dans une photo pour le
voir il faut une vidéo
c'est ainsi que smartpool propose
désormais non pas de photographier les
excréments mais de les filmer quelques
jours plus tard des centaines de
milliers de vidéos de quelques secondes
sont collectées par smart poupe katia
qui n'a pas dormi entre temps est alors
sur le point d'achever la conception de
nouveaux algorithmes de smart poupe
désormais adaptés à l'analyse de vidéos
à 4 heures du matin katia rentrer dans
la chambre de marque pour le réveiller
marc se réveille en sursaut court
chercher une bouteille de champagne et
rejoint katia dans le salon katia
explique qu'elle a entraîné son
algorithme avec 90% de la base de
données de smart poupe et qu'elle
s'apprête à tester les performances de
l'algorithme sur les 10% restants katia
explique que ces 10% restants ont été
tirés au hasard avec la simple
contraintes qu'ils contiennent autant
d'excréments affecté près symptomatique
que d'excréments sens si l'algorithme
échouent alors il aura un taux de
reconnaissance d'excréments de 50% s'il
est parfait sa précision sera de 100 %
il ne reste plus qu'à lancer le test de
l'algorithme pour connaître sa
performance kateri marque lance alors un
décompte 5 4 3 2 1 le thème on sait
dix secondes plus tard 10% du test est
effectué il faudra donc attendre encore
une minute et demie pour avoir les
résultats
pendant sept longues minutes et demie
katia et marc ont le souffle coupé
enfin le résultat s'affiche le verdict
52 4%
tête baissée marque se lève et part
mettre le champagne au réfrigérateur
katia elle s'affale dans le canapé quand
marc revient dans le salon cat et adore
déjà il va lui chercher une couverture
pour lui éviter de prendre froid
puis il va se coucher à son tour
lendemain marc se réveille à 15 heures
katia dort encore en fait katia dormir à
20 heures de suite
c'est encore au lieu de la nuit que
katia réveille tout à coup marque 5
écart type 5 écart-type répètent-elles
le test n'a pas échoué il est en fait
assez nettement au-dessus de 50% mais un
taux de succès de 52 4% ne nous aidera
absolument pas arrêter leur vie de 19
katia explique alors que en effet
l'algorithme actuelle est très largement
insuffisant cependant la supériorité de
52 4% par rapport à 50% cela suffit à
suggérer que smart poupe est bel et bien
en train de relever un signal distinctif
des excréments infecté seesmart poupe ne
détectait absolument rien alors on
s'attendrait à un taux d'erreur de 50%
explique katia mais pas exactement de
50% à cause des fluctuations
statistiques
sachant que le test a été effectué sur
des dizaines de milliers de vidéos
d'excréments on s'attendrait à obtenir
50% plus ou moins une erreur de l'ordre
de 0 5% or là on est à 52 4 % soit 2 4%
de plus que 50 % un écart de 2,4 pour
cent c'est donc presque cinq fois la
fluctuation de 0 5%
c'est beaucoup et ça veut dire que la
distinction existe très probablement
smartbook n'est simplement pas encore
capable de l'identifier marque de
montres à katia ce qu'il manque pour
discerner ce signal katia répond si on
veut diagnostiqué quoi que ce soit il
faut des données beaucoup de données et
il va nous falloir aussi beaucoup de
machines pour analyser toutes ces
données mais maintenant qu'on a cinq
écart type je suis sûr qu'on va pouvoir
trouver des investisseurs pour nous y
aider on tient notre pocock
katia et marc décidé alors de se lancer
à corps perdu dans le développement de
smart poupe katia démissionne de son
entreprise et passe désormais jour et
nuit à améliorer les algorithmes de
smart poupe à promouvoir l'application
est à chercher des investisseurs
loup alors plus de puissance de calcul
encore sur les serveurs d'amazon web
services et appelle aussi ses anciens
camarades de thèse pour qu'ils l'aident
dans le développement de smart poupe
marc lui passe son temps à tester smart
poupe et a suggéré les améliorations de
l'interface pour rendre son utilisation
plus facile et compréhensible pour tous
ses utilisateurs
marc le contacte également régulièrement
différents médias et les appelle à
promouvoir smart poupe pour recueillir
davantage d'utilisateurs et de données
science for alpha parle régulièrement
des progrès de smart pop dans ses vidéos
youtube et encourage ses collègues du
web en faire de même jour après jour la
performance de smart poupe s'améliore en
juillet 2020 elle passe à 50 5% en août
elle passe à 60 %
il marque sont désormais invités sur les
plateaux de télévision pour parler de
smart poupe les journaux nationaux
titrent filmer vos excréments pour
sortir du confinement